judaïsme est interdit au Portugal depuis
120 ans les nouvelles générations
grandit
sans synagogue
sans école sans littérature
à la domination de l'église
aujourd'hui le fait de posséder des
livres ou n'importe quel objet juif
serait dû suicide
j'ai remarqué certains comportements
étranges au sein de l'Église qui ont
éveillé mon attention il semble que les
Juifs en soi
Antonio Alvarez et Frédéric homogata les
hommes les plus riches de toute la ville
de Porto n'utilisez pas ce mot nous
pourrions nous attirer des ennuis le
Seigneur Dieu l'époque où le judaïsme se
pratiquant secret révoler
juste a convaincu le cœur des plus
réfractaires d'entre eux
presque là tous les juifs
sont devenus de bons chrétiens
j'ai le pressentiment qu'il va bientôt
se passer quelque chose
une figure importante de l'église est
arrivée ce matin rentre chez nous fais
vite s'il te plaît
[Musique]
des milliers de Juifs sont parmi nous
présents dans chaque classe sociale
les pactes avec le diable le cachot la
sorcellerie
tout cela prend fin
qu'un simple serviteur du
Christ ne signifie pas servir la justice
as-tu pensé à ta famille je veux partir
tu attends de vous de voir qu'allez-vous
faire à ma famille
[Musique]
nous partirons ce soir